he is considered to be one of the great
presidents in the history of the United
States
are there ways that he failed is there
things he could have done better so he
failed in the ways that most great
leaders fail
which is that he had a terrible
succession plan
his uh vice president who I spend a lot
of time on in the book Andrew Johnson
who is probably our worst president ever
uh Andrew Johnson had no business being
anywhere near the presidency Andrew
Johnson was the only Southern senator
who did not secede and so even though he
was a Democrat Lincoln wanted to show
that he was creating a Unity ticket when
he ran for re-election in 1864. this
happens today right so he puts someone
on as vice president who he didn't even
like but who we thought was politically
useful problem is when Lincoln was
assassinated this guy took over Andrew
Johnson was drunk at his own
inauguration the guy was a true drunkard
he was not prepared to lead in any sense
intellectually politically and he was
against most of the principles Lincoln
was for
and the irony is that when Lincoln is
assassinated in April of 1865 Andrew
Johnson takes over and he has all the
War Powers Lincoln had
that was not good Planning by Lincoln
and we can look back on it now and say
even though Lincoln is the first
president who was assassinated uh he
should have known that there were people
coming for him it wasn't inevitable that
he'd be assassinated but he should have
had a backup plan for who would take
over hopefully someone who was capable
of doing the job and Andrew Johnson was
not capable so for me for a person if I
were to put myself in in Lincoln shoes
or anybody any leadership position she
was
it is difficult to think about what
happens after my death after I'm gone
right to plan well at the same time
if you care about
your actions to have a long-term impact
it seems like you should have a
succession plan that continues on the
path yeah it continues to carry the
ideals that you've implemented
so I'm not I'm I'm unsure why people
don't do that more often like I wonder
how much Vladimir Putin spends
percentage of time
per day
thinking what happens after he's gone to
help flourish the nation and the region
that he deeply cares for I wonder and
the same as for other presidents Donald
Trump Joe Biden uh they might think
politically like how do I guarantee that
a democrat or a republican but do they
think like
um Visionary for the country I don't
know I wonder I think that's very rare
and I think uh what I understand from
the literature among business people who
talk about this a lot right is what ends
up happening is you become so powerful
you assume you're always going to be in
power you convince yourself of that you
convince yourself that the end is far
away and of course for Link in the end
could have been far away he was healthy
he was only in his 50s he could have
lived a lot longer
but it also it ended fast as it could
and and my understanding is that most
Americans don't prepare their Wills in
Estates and it doesn't matter whether
they're rich or poor they they assume
things are just going to go on because
it's not fun to think about this yeah
but I feel like it's freeing like you
know what I did which is interesting
before I went to Ukraine I recorded a
video I set up a whole thing where I
record a video like what happens if I
die I record a video to release I gave
my uh brother access to my passwords to
so that and I gave them instructions
you're not allowed to look at this but
please publish this if I die and you
know that made me uh it sounds silly and
ridiculous but uh that made me feel free
to do the best thing I want to do it's
like it's a it's a liberating so like I
guess that's for your will but also like
do the best possible damn job you can I
feel like as a leader having a plan what
happens if you if you and not if you
fail if you die if you um
or or you lose some of the um some of
the power some of the momentum that is
driving you currently that there's going
to be a handoff where you will still and
you will still be remembered as a great
man or woman that but you identify one
of the other problems right which is one
of the other reasons why someone like
Lincoln or some nice Henry Kissinger
doesn't create a successor because
you're afraid they're going to steal
your passwords you're afraid they're
gonna steal the power from you that's
true you had to find someone your
brother hopefully who you could trust
but let's just be clear I love my
brother but he's a troll so uh so
there's a feature on the past on
whatever password manager I may or may
not use uh and this is there's a bunch
of services like this it's interesting I
don't know if you you know about I've
learned about all this uh is you can
have them request access and it's going
to wait 30 days before it gives them
access so it's kind of has this um
built-in trust okay uh trust padding but
it's interesting I mean to me on that
aspect is just to have a plan in all
aspects of life this is for leadership
in your private life
like what happens
to not just your will and your wealth uh
your wealth or whatever but what happens
to other stuff like social media and all
that right in this Digital World
anything you care about if you wanted to
live on and that's the problem but if
you
unless you can devise
a technical solution like that you have
to give someone power now yeah and
that's the tricky thing I mean uh
democracy is a kind of Technology you're
going to have to figure out how to do it
correctly how to have how to have that
power propagate and especially during
war how you get everybody together into
this war-mongering mood or and then how
do you how do you like com come down
from that and just relax precisely so in
some sense that's
well there Johnson that was the the
problem is is the over centralization of
power it was the over centralization of
power but it was also that Lincoln
had a designated successor who was going
to do and tried to do everything that
ran against what Lincoln was doing and
it set the country back we went forward
at the end of the Civil War and then we
went backward
more so than we would have if there had
been a new election because if there had
been a new election there still would be
reason for that person running even if
they were on the other side to try to
find some compromise positions Andrew
Johnson inherited power
with very few limitations on how he used
that power Congress wasn't even in
session
and so this became very directly a
problem because Andrew Johnson started
pardoning Southerners allowing them to
come back into power
so we had like a few months where he
just went wild yeah
it's it's giving the car keys to someone
who's not prepared to drive but decided
that they're going to do what they want
with the car for a while